Thank you.
Okay, folks. Uh, very quick there.
There's really no time for reminders at
this point. Everything's kind of winding
down. Uh, but your numbers from your
project should be in the master
spreadsheet by Sunday at midnight.
Right? It's not It's really five
numbers, right? ECF value, your pricing,
the price per share, and your
recommendation. If you have a real
option, that's a fifth number. But if
you don't, then it's going to be blank
for that. Now, just enter it because I
need it for your Monday class. And I'll,
you know, and you'll see when you when
you get to the Monday class why I need
it. Second, your final project itself is
due on Monday by 5:00, which is right
after the class. Somebody complained
about that this morning and I said if
you're writing your project at 4:30,
you've already lost the script. So
hopefully you finished the project and
this putting finishing touches by the
time you get to Monday by 5:00 the
project is due as a PDF file with all of
the group members on that front page in
alphabetical order. just make my life
simpler because when I start entering
your grades, if you've sorted in terms
of who put in the most work and you put
your name on first, you just make my
life more difficult. So, nothing changes
anyway. So, put your final exam is a
week after that. I know I screwed up on
an email. I've been juggling all these
different dates. It's on the 12th from
4:00 to 5:50 p.m. If you're going to be
in New York, unless you've got my
permission, you need to be in class and
I'll send you the seating arrangements.
If you're not going to be in New York,
obviously it'll be online. It is it's
there's no multiple choice. It's
essentially the same kind of final exam
you've seen on previous final exams. So,
with that out of the way, let's talk
about the last piece of this class.
Today, we're going to talk about
changing the value of your company as
opposed to what? So far, our focus is on
estimating the value of your company,
right? How do you estimate the value?
Today, I want to talk about how do you
change the value of your company? Why
might you want to know the answer to
that question? who aan
one is if you're going to take over a
company change you're a new CEO of a
company how do I it could be that you
own a business right you value the
business then you ask me hey what can I
do to make my business more valuable
certain kind of sense and if you're
thinking in terms of jobs you're a
consultant and you're truly a consultant
not you know the kind that you used to
kind of pass off the buck to what's your
job? I call you in and I'm a troubled
company and say, "What can I do to make
myself more valuable?" You know what to
do. So, we're going to start this
session with a couple of questions about
changing value. The first question is
I'm going to list a series of actions.
And with each one, I'd like you to We
know what drives value, right, William?
Remind me again what are the things that
drive value? Cash flows, growth, and
risk, right? So, as I list out each of
these actions, the question you need to
ask is, will this affect cash flows
growth and risk? And how? a stock
split. Why not? What does a stock stock
split do?
Change the number of shares in a
company, right? That's like getting on
your weighing machine and changing it
from pounds to kilos and claim you lost
60% of your weight overnight, right?
It's still the same weight. It's
basically it changes nothing. Changes
the denominator. So, could it affect
price though? A stock split? It doesn't.
Why? What what what might lead you as a
trader to increase the price of stock
Sophia?
So maybe it increases the float. Maybe
it increases liquidity. Pricing is about
liquidity, demand and supply. It could
also be that we you send a signal that
people traders are constantly looking
for signals. What kind of signal? The
fact that you split your stock must mean
and this is in their minds that your
stock is going to go up in the future.
Otherwise, why would you do a 10 for one
stock split? It's subtle, but it can
happen. So, it can has no
value. We all know how goodwill gets
recorded on a balance sheet, right? How
does goodwill get recorded? What hap
what has to happen, Tyler, for goodwill?
First, goodwill shows up only if you
acquire another company. It's the
difference between what you paid and the
book value, right? And in today's day
and age, what happens after you've done
an acquisition is every year accountants
come back into your company, usually
invited, Ernston Young, Deoid, and their
job is to tell you whether your goodwill
has been
impaired. Say, how the heck do they
know? You know what they do? They look
at what you bought. They look at the
stock price in that sector. They're down
30%. Your goodwill is impaired. They'll
write off 30% of the
goodwill. So that's a goodwill
impairment. Could be a big charge,
billions of dollars. Does that affect
value?
Ahan. That's the question. Is the
amortization of goodwill tax deductible?
And in much of the world,
unfortunately, it's
not. So, but you raised the right
question. If it affects taxes, it
affects value. But because it's not
taxdeductible, there's one part of the
world where it is taxdeductible. Spain
allows you to claim it as a tax
deduction, which gives companies in
Spain an advantage. It's not tax, but it
doesn't affect your cash flows, growth,
or risk. It doesn't affect value. But
could it affect price? The the day the
goodwill impairment is announced, you're
going to announce this horrible
earnings. Traders react, right? They're
not deep thinkers. It might affect the
price. Changing depreciation methods,
but only in your reporting books. Let me
back up. US companies are allowed to
have two sets of books. The reporting
books are what you see in the earnings
report, the 10Ks, the the reports that
you and I have access to. But they also
are allowed to have a separate set of
tax books. It's one reason some of you
have companies with very strange
effective tax rates, tax rates that
exceed 100% negative tax. You say, "How
can that be?" Because you have two sets
of books.
So you're changing your depreciation
method from accelerated depreciation to
straight line depreciation just in your
reporting books. Why are you doing that?
What's the advantage of going from
accelerated to straight
line? You have less
depreciation which increases your
earnings and you say, "Hey, earnings
went up, right?" It's completely
cosmetic though because what's the
effect of depreciation? It's a tax
benefit and it's not showing up in your
tax books has no effect. You notice a
pattern here. So much of what companies
do you look at and say that's not
changing value. That's not changing
value. So why are they doing it? Because
it can affect
price. Companies play the pricing game
and it shows up in the kinds of actions
they push
out. Okay. So now I'm going to elevate
you to becoming the CEO of a multi-
business company. You've risen in the
ranks very
quickly. You're CEO of a company that
has four different divisions, right? And
it this might seem like a slam dunk, but
I want you to think about which of the
four divisions you see listed here. So,
you're the new CEO. There are four
businesses. I've listed out the return
on capital and cost of capital for each
of the four
businesses. It's one of the if you if
you want a good interview question, this
will be good when you want to torture
other people, right? So that'll come 2 3
5 years from now. Four businesses.
You're the CEO of the com this business.
If your objective is value
enhancement, which of these four
businesses would you devest?
D everybody kind of that's what this
entire business school experience has
been about, right? Teacher good. But
what's the effect of a devestature? You
get rid of a business and what do you
get in return? Whatever somebody pays
you for the business, right? You see the
catcher. You got rid of the bad
business. The people buying the business
know it's a bad
business. Yeah. They look at your return
capital. They pay based on it's a bad
business. The effect of a devestatured
value is not whether you're getting rid
of a good or a bad business, but what
the difference is between the business
to you as a continuing value and what
people will pay for that business.
This sounds complet. It's ironic, but
you know which of the these four
divisions you're most likely to get more
than fair value
be like your it's going to be your very
best B. You have this great software
business. Guess what? You're more likely
that people will overpay for that
business than for your worst businesses.
It kind of cuts against the grain,
right? Because you're told, get rid of
your bad businesses. Getting rid of a
bad business will not increase value if
you're getting rid of it for less than
what it would be worth if you just ran
the because remember at 3% returns on
capital the business is making money.
It's just not making very much
money. So we're going to talk about what
to do about businesses that don't pull
their weight and how to pull the trigger
on whether to keep the business going or
devest. So we're laying the foundations
for value enhancement, but we have a few
things still to cover on
on synergy. So, let's go back and look
at where I left you on the synergy
discussion. Tyler, remind me again what
the value of synergy is. What is
synergy and can do things that they
could not have done as standalone
companies, right? So, let's say we want
to value synergy. To value synergy,
you've got to go through a three-step
process. First, you got to value the
acquiring company and the target company
standing alone. You can never value
synergy by looking at just the target
company. This is how you know 80% of
banking synergy valuations are not worth
the paper they're printed on because
it's only the target company. The
essence of synergy is both companies
kind of gain from that combined company.
You value the two companies standing
alone. That's step one. Step two, add
those two values
up. Values additive. What does that give
you? It'll give you the value of the
combined company if there's no
synergy. Step three, value the combined
company with everything but the kitchen
sink thrown in. All the synergies you
list, cost savings, growth synergies,
lower cost of capital, value the
combined company with the synergies
built in. The difference you get from
what you get in step three and what you
had in step two is the value of
synergy. So let's try this out. I'm
going to start with a very simplistic
example. It's actually a very big merger
when it
happened. So when Brock Proctor and
Gamble at that time the largest consumer
product in company in the world bought
Gillette which was the fifth largest
consumer product company in the world
and talk of synergy filled the air. So I
did a bestase valuation of synergy. In a
minute I'll explain why I call it best
case. So what's the first thing I need
to do? I need to value Proctor and
Gamble standing alone. And I did and I
came up with the value of $221 billion
for the company. Then I had a valuation
of Gillette standing alone and I came up
with a value of 59.9 billion for that
company. Then I combined the two
companies. I called it Piglet but they
chose to call PNG Gillette kind of it
would have been a good name for them but
they stayed with PNG combined. And if
you combine the two companies with no
synergy the sum of the values is going
to be 281.2. That is my value of the
combined company with no synergy. Then
here's what I did. You know how managers
promise they can do things? I took their
promises at face value and assumed they
could do them
instantaneously. They talked about
cutting cost by 250 million. I said, "I
believe you. It'll happen tomorrow." How
likely is that to really play out? No,
but this is a best case valuation. I cut
the co the cost by 250 million. It
pushes up their margin and operating
income. They also talked about growing
at a slightly higher rate. Why only
slightly largest consumer product
company in the world buys the fifth
largest. They already have dominant
market shares. You're not going to get
10% increase in growth. That's about a
1% increase in growth. I put that in
there. So lower cost, higher growth
rate. The value that I got for the
combined company with the synergies
built in was $298
billion. There's a canard that in
finance we don't give value to synergy.
That's not true. I'm valuing synergy at
17.2 billion, right? This must have been
a good deal. What have I not told you
though?
What will determine whether this was a
good deal for Proctor and Gamble?
Sophia,
how much they paid as a premium, right?
You know what they paid as a premium?
$25 billion. And then we wonder why M&A
doesn't pay off for acquiring companies.
You take a best case valuation of
synergy and you pay $8 billion more. How
the heck will you make your money back?
But let's step back from that best case
scenario and think about a more base
case scenario. What did I assume in my
best case that everything managers say
they would do they would do and they
would do it right away. Let's take the
250 million. Let's say typically
managers deliver 80% of what they
promise in cost cuts. And I'll give you
a table to back this up. So what's the
first thing you're going to do? We're
going to take the $250 million promise
and make it an expected cost cut of 200
million. I know we're being cynical, but
you have to be realistic. Let's say you
have to wait 2 years for the synergy to
show up because that's how long it's
going to take. How would you adjust the
value of synergy? If you have to wait
two years to get the synergy, take the
17.2
billion, discount it back. But now comes
the question at whose cost to capital?
It's a combined company's cost of
capital. So basically, always go back to
first principles, right? It's a combined
company that's getting this value. It's
got to be the com. So when you value the
target company, we said always use the
target company's cost of capital. But
synergy belongs to both firms. You take
the combined company's cost of capital.
That'll make the 17.185 billion into 14
or 14 or 12 or 13. And already you can
see why being realistic on synergy
requires that you ask all those
questions. So we'll do one more example
in synergy and then we'll put it to kind
of
slow. You've heard of Zenith, right?
Oldtime electronics of there was a time
in the US where TVs were made by Zenith
and you walked into any US household
there' be a Zenith TV. Those days are
done. You know the only asset Zenith had
at the time that did this assessment?
They had an NOL of $2 billion. That's
kind you're kind of low on the ground on
the only thing that we've lost a lot of
money immense amounts but it's still a
valuable asset to somebody who makes
money right so let's say you're a best
buy and you're buying Zenith not for the
brand name who cares about the brand
name but for the $2 billion nol this is
a very simple synergy to value let's see
what value it attach to it what's the
value of having an
NOL teller you can pay less in taxes
it's It's as simple as that. So, if your
tax rate is 36% and you're buying a $2
billion NOL, that gives you a tax
savings of $720 million. 36 if you have
enough income. Remember, the IRS doesn't
mail you a check for 720 million. You
got to have taxable income. So, if you
have taxable income of 3 billion or 5
billion, the value of the NOL to you
will be about 720 million. But let's
make it a little trickier. Let's suppose
you have a half a billion dollars in
expected taxable income. This will be
Best Buy's taxable income each year for
the next four years. You'll still get
the 720 million tax benefits, but it'll
be 180 million year 1, 180 million year
2, 180 million year 3, and 180 million
year four. Right? So here I'm going to
ask you a question again about discount
rates. Let's see if you can go back to
basics to give me the right answer. I
need a discount rate to discount 180
million back to the present. What
discount rate should I use,
Sophia? Okay. Of which company? Best Buy
or
Zenith? This is actually on one of the
final exams way back in time. So, let's
see if we can of
of Best Buy. You're actually right. Tell
me why though you're going to use Give
me the reasoning that led you to that
right answer.
change cash flows to defer from this
right is basically what best buy
shareholders
it's not just that you're thinking about
where is the risk in this transaction
right is it in the
nol a billion the risk is in your
taxable income not being there and it's
best buys taxable income right zenith is
out of the picture so it's in the
taxable income and taxable income is
after interest expenses which is an
equity income. So whenever you run into
issues about discount rates, always go
back to where is the risk coming from.
It's the same reasoning we used when we
valued the remember the the drugs to
biogen that we valued at the cost of
debt of mercy. Go back and ask where is
the risk here because that's always
going to give you the right answer. I
see bankers mangling NOL because they
often set them to the side and they try
to deal with it. You will run into this
in practice. Try to use first
principles. Talk about what is that
right discount rate to use. So if you
were to summarize the lessons about
synergy, don't make it a buzz word.
Don't make it a plug variable because
then you're going to overpay for
synergy. Second, to value synergy, you
have to be
specific. So if you tell me, oh, we'll
grow more if we're combined company.
Where and what? You say, I haven't
thought about that. We'll do the
acquisition, then we'll grow more. It's
not going to work, right? You got to be
specific. And for two reasons. Not only
do you need to be specific to value it,
but if you're specific, you also have a
plan of action after you do the merger
to actually deliver on that synergy. If
you remember that KPMG study that showed
that in 83% of merges, synergy never
shows up. It's perhaps because you never
plan for
it. And we did draw this line between
control and synergy. It's a subtle line,
but it's a line worth remembering. If
you were to summarize the key
distinction between what goes into
control and what goes into synergy, what
would that distinction
be? Where does control come
from
Sophia? You can run the business
different. You don't need the outsider,
right? The target company can
effectively do it. The difference in
control and synergy is for synergy you
need both companies. Control can happen
with that target with the target company
just fixing itself. And the reason we
separate the two and we treat them
differently is the way you negotiate for
each one. Remember your objective as the
acquiring company may be different for
control than for
synergy. And how much you get of each
will depend on you know how much power
you have in this process to bargain for
that for a greater share. So, any
questions on synergy? Because you're
going to run into all kinds of synergy.
Going back to basics will always tell
you how to deal with that
synergy. Let's talk about pricing.
Talked about pricing before we got to
M&A, right? What's the essence of
pricing? You decide how much to pay
based on what other people are paying
for similar things. So, I'm going to go
back to playing my role as a banker.
Remember, my my objective was to try to
get you to pay more than 60 million,
that base case value. you've been very
resistant every step of the way. So now
I hit you with a couple of big I think
selling points. I say look if I look at
other companies that have been acquired
in the last 6 months in this
sector acquirers have paid about five
times
EBIT. This target company is 20 million
EBIT. 5* 20 is 100
million. It's a pricing right? We do it
all the time in pricing. So, you know,
and if you're resistant to doing that,
what if I move it to the 10th year or
the fifth year? Make it an exit multiple
to get the terminal number. Basically,
I'm putting a pricing in. If you're
acquiring a company, I mean, in trading,
we price all the time because traders
make money. And what's the essence of
trading? You buy at a low price, you
sell at a high price. So, I understand
the pricing game. Why can't you
transport that into M&A as the acquiring
company? You buy at a price,
William. You don't want to sell it,
right? The entire objective of doing an
acquisition is you want to bring that
company in. You want to change the way
the business is run. If you are truly
doing an acquisition to build a
business, you're buying it for the cash
flows. And moving it to year five, year
10, year 15 doesn't make that go away.
Sophia much more different from each
other. So, into the first five companies
in the industry were worth paying five
times a uh why wasn't this company sold
earlier and they're all kind so we can
talk about the pure group and what else
happens but you can see already
psychologically pricing shouldn't be
what you're doing in acquisitions
because you're building a
business so finally I hit you with a
word that I hear bankers use all the
time and they're trying to get you to do
an acquisition say you're being very
resistant to all the stuff I'm telling
you But this deal is going to be
accretive. The most dangerous word you
hear in M&A is the word accretive.
Claire, what does the word accretive
mean?
Buying it less than what your earnings
per share will go up. That's a it's
basically if you do this deal, your
earnings. So what kinds of companies or
how would you have to structure a
transaction for a deal to be a created?
It's a pure math problem. Your PE ratio
is 20. You buy a stock with a PE ratio
of 12, your earnings per share is going
to go up, right? You buy a lower PE
company. You borrow money and do an
acquisition, your earnings per share is
going to go up because the share count
stays the same. So, you're telling me
that any deal that I borrow money on is
a good deal because you can already see
that a creative is an empty word, but
you see it thrown around. Good deals are
accreative. Bad deals are dilutive.
But you can already see you can have a
good deal that's dilutive and a bad deal
that's secret agreive. It's got nothing
to do with whether you're getting a fair
value, but it's become the shortcut of
the deal is good if it's a creative. So
let's take this apart. One of my
problems with pricing at least in the
context of
acquisitions is while I accept that
pricing is okay, this is particularly
bad pricing for a couple of reasons. In
many acquisitions, the pricing is based
not on all other companies or a pure
group of other companies in the sector.
It's based on other companies that have
been acquired in M&A deals. Do you see
the danger here? What do we start this
class with? In acquisitions, people
generally overpay. If you take that
subsample of people of companies that
have been acquired, you almost are
biasing yourself to overpay just because
everybody else is overpaid. It's a
biased sample. So it's not even a good
pricing and if you let me pick the
multiple to use and the sample you've
lost the script right because I'm can
basically convince you that anything
looks
cheap as for the word you know pushing
it to your five year 10 year 15 doesn't
say change any of those metrics so in
M&A this is standard practice people use
exit multiples they use these you know
these transaction multiples is what they
call them because they're looking at a
pure group of companies that require But
it's bad pricing and pricing to begin
with is a dangerous road to follow in
acquisitions and this becomes a bad
pricing on top of
that. So if you decide to go down this
road, you got to decide why you decided
on doing acquisitions the first place.
Are you in this game to get cash flows
and change your business? Are you in
this game as a trader where you're
buying companies and flipping them to
other people? If it's a ladder, then by
all means go ahead and do pricing. But
at least do an honest pricing. Pick up
your group just like you're doing on
your
company and do a pricing based on all
other companies in the group rather than
just the subset of companies that have
been acquired. And along the way, don't
get distracted by words like a creative
and dilutive. Hey, when you listen to
them, just let it go through one year,
go out of the other year, just pass on
because it tells you absolutely nothing
about the quality of the deal.
So, at this stage, we're still stuck at
60 million,
right? So, now I hit you with a couple
of what I think are things you cannot
fight. They say, "Look, you're being
very resistant, but I need to tell you
that your CEO really, really, really
wants to get this deal done." What's the
implicit message there?
If you're getting very resistant, I'm
going to go above you and the CEO is
then going to find somebody else to
replace you. perhaps permanently. It's
very kind of a veiled threat or not so
veiled. So we'll talk about how in many
deals this process we blame the bankers
and the poor middle management involved.
But the real people we should be blaming
the CEO of the acquiring company woke up
one morning saying I want to do a deal.
Maybe he had a dream and this is his
version of delivering on that dream. So
that's one thing we're going to talk
about is CEOs whose egos drive this
decision process and how you're then
left holding the bag of how do I justify
something that cannot really be
justified and to make you feel better
and this is to give you legal cover. I
say you
know not only does your CEO want it but
after you do this deal I can get Goldman
Sachs to sign a
fairness opinion that says whatever you
paid is fair. What does it what does
this get you?
It protects you. So you overpay, your
shareholders can't sue you. I know it
sounds almost borderline
unethical, but you have a job at at at
stake, right? So don't be so quick to
judge because if you're in a company
that's acquisitive, you will be in this
place. You're looking for reasons to get
the deal done because you know it makes
your life
easier. There's another version of a
pitch that I can make as well. You're in
a business where other companies are
consolidating. You know what that means,
right? They're acquiring each other.
They're getting bigger. And I tell you,
if you don't do this deal, you're going
to end up being the outlier where you're
going to be the small company. It's
called defensive mergers. you're doing
it not because the deal actually creates
value, but if you don't do it, you will
lose even more
value. So, I'm going to take each of
those those pieces because clearly there
these are things that often tip the
scales even for people who are sensible
about using the right discount rate and
talking about getting through all of the
first five hurdles. Let's first talk
about CEO
egos. You know, when you look at um at
many deals, the definition of winning is
that you get the deal done. And in my
experience, once a deal gets started,
it's very difficult to get it stopped
because the winning becomes getting the
deal done, right? And egos get in the
way, right? Cuz when you lose a deal as
a CEO, it's your, you know, I used to
think therefore that if women became
CEOs, this would happen less. But it
turns out women who become CEOs have
egos just as big as men who become CEOs.
So maybe this is a CEO thing. Okay. The
kinds of people who become CEOs tend to
be there's a selection bias. You know
who becomes CEOs is those people in high
school who know very little but strut
around as if they know everything. They
end up ruling the high school. You think
karma is going to catch up with you? You
know how it catches up with them? They
keep rising up the ranks. They become
CEOs. They become presidents. they
become prime ministers. Basically, the
world rewards overconfident people
especially if they can carry it off and
they become CEOs of companies. They
carry that
around. So the reality is if you look at
know we started by talking about how M&A
breaks down. But I think one of the
reasons it breaks down is because you
got top management spending other
people's
money and then having an ego problem
because they can't step away from deals
that they've initiated.
Nothing you can do about it as middle
management other than try to find
another company to work for and maybe
you need to do a CEO ego test before you
join a company right you want to go to
companies with know today's day and age
I would check to see what the CEO's
Twitter profile is and what is social
media for you want people who are kind
of muted on that front because that's
the last place you want to end up even
across CEOs of of the mag seven right
how often do you see Tim Cook come out
with something I mean the guy you know
whatever you think about him clearly
doesn't is not ego-driven in terms of
his action shows up in no big
acquisitions as for defensive mergers I
understand I understand that in
businesses that consolidate being the
company that doesn't do acquisitions
puts you at a
disadvantage so you're saying only way I
can survive in this business is by going
out and overpaying on acquisitions but
what does it tell you about the state of
your business that the Only way you can
survive in this business is by
overpaying on mergers to stay in the
business. Is it a good business or a bad
business? You're in a bad business. You
hear this argument with airlines all the
time. We have to consolidate. Why?
Because if we don't, we're going to be
you're going to be at a disadvantage
even after you consolidate because your
core business is bad. Long term, you
know what you should be thinking about
doing, right? How do I get out of this
business and get smaller?
So if your only way to survive is with
defensive mergers, you've already lost
the game because this is not a good
business to be in. Earning more than
your cost of capital is going to be
tough. So if there's a lesson that you
get out of all of this is if you define
winning as getting a deal done, I
guarantee you you will win every single
deal. All you have to do is do
what? If your definition is I want to
win deal, you just pay more than the
next best guy, right? It's like being on
eBay. If you tell yourself I have to
have this item, you will,
right? Just set you I think you can set
an order for eBay, the price goes up,
you would have an extra 5%. The only
problem is the other person might have
just as big a stake. So by the time
you're done, you're paying 50,000 for
something you thought you going to pay
5,000 for.
Second, when you look at the premiums
that people pay for, and they call it
synergy control, most of the time, you
know what the premiums for? You're
paying it for the CEO ego. You want to
get the deal done. That's why people
leave it as buzzwords because it sounds
good, but really the reason you're
paying an 80% premium is because this
deal needs to get done. Third, if you're
doing a lot of defensive mergers, that's
not a good sign by the business. You can
give me a good argument that maybe this
business will come back and you want to
stay, but I want to hear that argument
before giving you a blank check to go
out and continue to do these
deals. Which brings me to my seventh
test. Deals go bad. And we saw on
average how many deals go bad. And when
a deal goes bad, there are lots of
reasons why it can go bad. The managers
might have misestimated, mismanaged the
company after the merger. The bankers
and the boards are all involved. their
deal. A a a big deal has a 100 parents.
When that deal falls apart, it's an
orphan. I wasn't there. Who got this
deal
done? So, I'll give you an example of a
deal that unraveled really quickly to
kind of illustrate
this. This is in 2008 2009. HP company
you've all heard of. Legendary company,
right? because it was the first company
that actually created Silicon Valley,
right? Hulet and Packard in their garage
and technology took off. Been around a
long time. Great history. But by the
2000s, it was down on it. They' got rid
of their original CEO, a guy called Mark
Herd, because he'd had some personal
indiscretions that got him fired. And a
new CEO had been hired, a guy called
Leo. Let's lead into the story. They buy
this company called Autonomy. It's a
British business services software
company. The company was trading at 5.9
billion. They paid 11.1 billion. It's a
percentage premium of what 80% or
so. In fact, this graph shows you how
you get from the book value of autonomy
2.1 billion to the so basically I've
taken in steps. This is how you get to
the 11.1 billion. That was the original
book value of equity right after the
deal was announced. I think an
accounting firm. I don't remember which
one came in and revalued the existing
assets. You're actually allowed to do
this in an acquisition. So the target
company book value got written up to 4.6
billion. They added 2.5 billion
magically overnight. I don't know where
they found the value, but they found it.
The market was at 5.9 billion. So
there's an extra 1.3 billion. And then
HP paid an extra 5.2 billion. and the
time of the deal they justified it by
saying there's lots of synergy there are
strategic reasons etc etc they paid so
much as one of the few deals where
everybody looked and said this is way
too much so a few weeks after this deal
was announced Leoa the CEO of HP was in
front of a group of equity research
analysts who are asking for once asking
pointed questions about the deal so I'm
going to read Leo's words as he said
them because I don't want to accused of
putting words in his mouth. So these are
the words he uttered in front of the
equity research analyst. He said we have
a pretty
rigorous process. I don't know what the
pretty is doing in front of the
rigorous. Now why why put it in there?
You should say we have a regular. So the
pretty is either making it better or
worse. I don't know what it is inside HP
that we follow for all our acquisitions
which is a D.
C.F based process. I don't know what the
base is doing in there. You have either
a DCF or you don't. And I don't usually
put a dot between the C and the F. But
no, I, you know, I'll concede that maybe
that's the way things work. He said in
reference, and this is the Wall Street
Journal filling it in for readers who
don't know what D, C, and F stand for,
which must be a fair number, discounted
cash flow. And then we're back to Leo,
and he says, we try to take a very
conservative view. This is to the
accountants in the audience, I guess.
You know, we're very conservative. and
let's keep going. He should have stopped
right there. He said just to make sure
everybody understands autonomy will be
on day one
accretive to HP. The magic word has
popped up. Just take it from us. We did
that analysis at great length in great
detail. Lots of great keep going to the
grades. And we feel we paid a very fair
price for autonomy and will give a great
return to our
shareholders. Most times it takes a
while for these things to unfold. A year
later, HP took the 11.1 billion and rode
it back down to 2.3 billion. It took an
$ 8.8 billion write off. There's a lot
of explaining to do,
right? So, let's So, I decided I wrote a
post still on my blog somewhere where I
decided I wanted to allocate
blame. I wanted to hold people
responsible. I say, "Okay, who made this
mistake?" because everybody said, "Not
my mistake. The janitor must have done
it when we weren't watching." And they
probably fired the poor janitor for
something he had no role in creating. So
I started allocating blame. I allocated
4.4 billion to the old CEO. Leop by then
had moved on to a different CEO position
somewhere else. You know, you never fall
down, you fall up the ranks, I guess.
And as a secondary culprits, I will put
the dealmakers, the bankers involved. So
apothecar they about 4.5 billion there
was some accounting impropriy in fact HP
blamed the whole thing on accounting
impropriy and I there was something
shady going on about 1.7 billion it was
deote who was the accountant so I said
they need to be punished as well and
then I said you know what the remaining
write off came from the fact that the
current management of HP which at that
point was Meg Wittmann I think she'd all
she'd come
in lots of people responsible right so
the banker's fee should be clawed back
Leopico should get back his
bonuses Deoid should be fined you know
what
actually happened after this none of
these people were held
responsible that's at the core of the
M&A problem until we hold people
accountable for mistakes why do we
expect the mistakes to
stop and I've never understood why the
accountability is so weak in M&A because
it's almost like we I don't think we
should have an M&A class. I should be
I'll be quite honest cuz when you go to
an M&A class, you you treat this almost
I mean why isn't it just an extension of
capital budgeting? Why do I need an M&A
class to know that I need a positive net
present value in a project? When you go
to an M&A class, you're given all these
escape hatches. You don't need an NP.
You can do this, you can do that. And as
a consequence, we create exactly this.
There's no accountability.
So, this is a pretty negative
perspective on M&A. I know a couple of
you are going to work in M&A and you're
re-examining your life saying, "What the
hell do I do now?" At this stage, it's
too late. Take the job. Right. So, so
I'm going to give you some a glimmer of
hope. And to see what the glimmer of
hope in acquisitions is, I'm going to
make you let you make choices. You're a
company. You're intent on growing
through acquisitions. I'm going to give
you choices on where you think value
enhancement is going to be more likely
to happen.
you're in an M&A deal. Would you rather
be a soul bidder or would you like to be
in a bidding war? This is an easy
one. Soul bidder. And if you're going to
be in a bidding war, do you want to win
the bidding war or lose the bidding
war? Okay, I'll let you win. I'll let
William lose. Let's see who comes out
because I have the the evidence on what
winners and losers from the bidding war
do in terms of stock prices. Right.
Second question. Would you rather go
after public targets, publicly traded
companies or privately owned
businesses? Tyler said public. Samita,
you
agree?
Claire. What's the key difference
between going after a public versus a
private? No one else knows the
financials of that business. It's even
if they know the financials, there's one
more number with a public company that
gets to become the starting number. So
when you acquire a public company, what
do you need to start with? The market
price. The market price is a problem,
right? Because who knows what's already
embedded in there. With a private
company, at least you start with the
negotiated value and you can say, I'm
going to put this in. I'm going to take
that out. The problem with public
companies, you start with the market
price and you go up from there. You've
already made the game a much more
difficult game to win. Would you rather
pay with cash or pay with stock?
Sophia, they overcharge. You have a very
convoluted way of getting
to I you know, but ultimately though
you're paying the same amount, right?
Either way, what might induce you to pay
with
stock, William?
pay with cash for this. What are you
signaling or who are you signaling it to
that it's their cash or their either way
that they pay the 8 billion or 10
billion, right? So, I'm not sure that
the due diligence signal is going to be
that effective. Yeah,
now we're talking, right? If you think
your stock is overpriced, you're trying
to pay with stock because it's
overpriced currency. The only problem is
when you decide to do that, what do the
other shareholders and here's where
Sophia's counter is going to come. I'm
the shareholder in a target company. You
tell me you're paying with shares. You
send me a signal. And what's the signal
you've sent me? You think your stock is
overpriced. So what do I do? I push up
my premium and this becomes this really
messy complex game of who's going to
win. Let's again look at the evidence
because the net effect can end up being
positive or negative. Would you rather
go after a small
target or a large target? Merges of
equals or merges of unequals. Where do
you think the odds are better?
Do you when two large companies come
together, are there issues you
think? What do you think? Good. I mean,
it's like two elephants mating, right?
It's awkward. It's going to be, you
know, all kinds of issues come up.
There's I mean, we talk about culture
clashes. I remember talking to a
Chrysler manager after Daimler bought
them. Talk about two very different
cultures. Daimler's classic German
culture. Chrysler was this let loose
Detroit culture. They couldn't get
along. Took seven years and finally
Daimler gave up. Mergers of equals have
much more issues. Merges of unequals,
you just impose your culture on the
small company. It's like colonialism.
You basically say you're a small
country. you either take it or you're
going to take it you know you can't
leave it now so mergers of you know
small versus again we'll look at the
evidence finally would you rather go for
a merger with cost
synergies or growth
synergies what do you think
William you'd go for growth synergies
what's the and which is going to be
easier to deliver right which are more
like what's the advantage of cost
synergies they're more explicit right
I'm going to close a 100 branches.
What's growth synergy? Oh, we're going
to grow more in that country, right?
It's more fuzzy. And because it's more
fuzzy, people don't put numbers down.
It's an empirical question, right? So,
let's look at each of those choices.
Let's start with the bidding war
question, right? We had one bidding war
winner and one bidding war loser. This
is a graph that looks at what happens to
the stock price. Very old graph. You can
see it's a primitive spreadsheet. Okay.
Basically, it looks at I know it's even
difficult to tell which one's a winner,
which one's a loser. But there are two
lines here. The way to read these lines
is the line goes up, your stock is doing
well. If the line goes down, your stock
is doing
badly. Guess which one is the winner.
There's the winner. There's the loser.
What does that tell you? If you're a
shareholder in a company that's trying
to acquire another company, it's in a
bidding war. Every night before you go
to bed, get down on your knees and say,
"Please God, let my company lose this
bidding war." short term it'll hurt
their ego but long term that's better
for me than actually winning a bidding
war. So the next time you see a Wall
Street Journal article that says company
wins bidding war track its stock price
and see how it stock price does in the
days
after. This is a messy graph to read. So
let me summarize what so what I'm trying
to do in this graph is looking at the
returns I can make when I do small
deals. So the blue is small and the
purple is large and the two
intermediate. So basically this is the
size of the target company relative to
you. So less than 6% means this the
company you're buying is less than 6% of
the value of your
company. I've broken it down to cash
deals, stock deals, combo deals. Let's
start with the all deals because it
summarizes all across all deals. It's
it's easy to see. Small deals you get
that slight positive blue. As a deal
gets
bigger, the numbers get worse. It's much
easier to get value creation with small
deals than big deals. If you look at
cash versus stock, you get this kind of
messy message. If you're doing stock
deals with small companies, you you
actually benefit from stock deals. Maybe
because even if you have a high price,
they take it. As the deal gets bigger,
that gaming comes into play, which is
you're paying with stock. It's a really
big deal. I look at you and say you're
paying with stock, that must mean you're
overpriced. that. So the question of
cash versus stock, the way I would
answer it is if you're doing really
small
deeds, you can use stock if it's
overpriced and you get away with it. If
you're doing really big deals, even
though it cuts against every grain of
your being, you're better off paying
with cash because otherwise your premium
gets so high that you give up whatever
benefits you
get. Here I'm comparing what acquiring
companies make when they buy public
targets, private targets and
subsidiaries of other of public
companies. So let's start with the p
private versus public with every across
all kinds of deals small versus large
and especially in the largest deals.
There's the public companies the blue
there's the red which is the private
businesses. You're more likely to create
value by buying private business in
public because you don't have that
market price starting point. But there's
also a very interesting side story here
which is what's even better than buying
private companies is buying subsidiaries
that public companies are trying to get
rid of. How would you explain
that? Yeah.
Subsidiary particularly a bad one.
They're going to try and go for the 30.
They might sell it to you really cheap.
They'll sell it to you for nothing.
Because guess what? When this happens, a
new CEO comes in, what are they trying
to do? Get rid of the old guys mistakes.
They want to clear the table to make
their own big
mistakes. They want to get rid of it at
any cost. It's a terrible way to run a
business. They get rid of deficiency at
any cost. That's how Tarta Motors was
saved as a company because Ford sold
Jaguar Land Rover to them at 2009 at any
cost. They was that desperate. So if
you're creating an acquisition strategy,
there's a way to get there. And finally
on cost versus growth synergies, this is
a McKenzie study that looked at the
likelihood of them being delivered. And
the way to read this is these are cost
synergies and it gives you the number of
companies. There were 92 companies in
their sample that delivered what they
promised. 36 of the 92 actually
delivered more than 100% of what they
promised in terms of cost cuts. It's
pretty impressive. And in fact, across
the sample, the median number was about
80 to 90%. So when peop when companies
predict cost synergies, they're able to
deliver about 80 to 90%. When you look
at growth synergies, you can already see
a problem, right? It's all over the
place. The median number is closer to 40
to 50%. For whatever reason, growth
synergies seem to be less likely to show
up. And I think the reason is when you
have growth synergies, companies are not
explicit about them. They let them be
fuzzy. And if it's fuzzy, much more
difficult to deliver. Yes, Sophia.
Practice client survey. That's
well remember they this this is
basically on they track their own
clients and your own clients you're
going to give them advice and then
whether they cut the cost or not it's
not on you because you give them the
advice if they don't do it it's not if
this were an assessment of their own
advice would be very different. So these
are often company picked targets and
they have a tougher time delivering on
those targets. Yes.
It sets
value to
Oh, you could I'm not saying growth
can't have value, but people don't try.
That's the problem is they're not
willing to make it explicit because it
gives them the free run of there's going
to be growth. They don't have to be
explicit. I agree with you. The growth
synergies can be valued and if you value
them, you'll make them explicit. If you
make them explicit, it gets easier to
plan and deliver on them. So it really
is a practice question rather than can
it be done. Of course it can be done but
companies don't want to try to do it. So
if I were to summarize what we've
learned in acquisitions no there is a
way to have a successful M&A strategy
but it does require that you stay
disciplined. You know what I mean by
disciplined? Let's say the way you
create values by buying small
privatelyowned businesses, changing how
they get run and making them part of
your company. It's work for you. So
discipline means you got to stay with
it. You're saying what's so what's the
problem with staying with it? Let's say
you're successful at it. You buy the
first 10, then 20. So as you do this,
what's happening to you as a company?
You're getting bigger as a company,
right? What does that require for you to
keep growing? you have to now buy 20
small private businesses instead of 10
because you're now a bigger company and
you're going to get tempted. Tempted by
what? By saying maybe you should make
our acquisitions a little
bigger. It'll make our life easier.
Already you can see the seeds for how
the discipline starts to fade.
Eventually there will be a point we have
to stop and say it's not working for us
anymore. And knowing when to stop is
critical here. We talked a little bit
about Cisco if you remember a long time
ago in this class, right? Company that
was incredibly successful growing
through acquisitions between 1990 and
2000. They had a SWAT team. It actually
called it a SWAT team where they do an
acquisition of a company with a
promising product. The SWAT team would
arrive at that company and then go
through the process of converting the
promising product into a commercial
product. They were very good at doing
it. Their market cap went from 4 billion
in 1991 to 400 billion in 1999. They
were one of the big winners of the
dotcom
boom. But when you're a $400 billion
company, think of how many small
companies you got to buy to even make a
dent on your growth rate. But they
tried. And over the next 10 years, the
400 billion market cap went back to 100
billion. The same strategy stopped
working, but they kept trying. So
discipline basically is tough. It's
easier said than done, but that's the
key. If you're in a bidding war, just
drop out. No, it's it's as simple as
that. And if somebody is actively
pushing for an acquisition, and every
acquisition is an advocate. Somebody
says, "We have to do this." You know
what you should do? Say, "Okay." And
then take what they give you as as
forecast. You're now going to be
responsible for delivering the forecast.
You'll be amazed at how quickly the
forecasted numbers will come down when
somebody is told you'll be responsible
delivering that 100 billion in synergy.
You see, we have to hold people
accountable.
And finally, if you think
about the
ecosystem that feeds this
addiction, the bankers, the deal makers,
I think we've got to figure out some
mechanism for clawback on deals that
have gone so bad like the autonomy deal
where you're required to actually give
your deal fees. That's a minimum. I'm
not even asking you to cover the cost.
Just give your deal fees back. These
were advisory fees. What kind of stupid
advice it is? Is it for me to pay a
hundred billion dollars more than I
should and still have to pay you
money? The process is broken and unless
it gets fixed, we'll keep seeing what
we've seen for much of the last few
decades. Which brings us to the last
segment of this class. Talk about
changing value. For those who are going
to consulting, owning your own business,
this is a key question. How do I change
the value of a company? To set the
stage, I want to draw a distinction
between enhancing value and enhancing
price. And I'm going to give you my
favorite example to illustrate the
difference. In the 1990s, do boom,
stocks were
surging. And this study actually looked
at 64 companies, I think, that changed
their name. Guess what they did? Boom.
What do you need to do? They added com
to their
names. Now let me ask you a question.
And these were 64 companies with changed
nothing about their operations. So you
were plumbing company and you said I'm
plumbing
company. You still had to fix the pipes
and do the plumbing. From a value
perspective, completely meaningless,
right? Changing your name doesn't change
your cash flows, your growth, or your
risk. But take a look at what happened
to their stock price. Many of these were
really small companies. on average their
stock prices doubled when they added.com
to their names. You're saying we've been
wasting 15 weeks talking about cash
flows growth and risk. We should really
have been talking about what's the right
name for your company. Think of all the
fun we could have had, right? But here's
the
catch. In 1999, adding.com to your name
increased your price by
100%. Then the com boom
bust. Now having.com in your name had
become a contaminant. So this is a study
from four years later and these
companies also changed their names.
Guess what they did? They took.com out
of their names. The stock price jumped
again. This is exactly why you don't try
to keep the market happy, right? It's
like it's a it's a it's a bipolar. It
can't make up its mind about what it
likes, what it doesn't like. You're
going to be jumping around trying to
deliver what the market wants. Too many
CEOs think their job is to gauge market
mood and play to that mood. and you can
see the pair. I'm not interested in
price enhancement because I have no idea
how you announce prices on a sustainable
basis. Maybe it's a name change, maybe
it's a stock split. I want to focus on
value enhancement. And here we know what
you need to do to enhance value. There
are only four pathways, right? You can
increase your cash flows from your
existing assets by doing what? Cutting
costs, more efficient operations. We'll
talk about all the different layers. You
can increase your value from growth by
doing one of two things. by reinvesting
more if you're in a good
business or reinvesting less if you're
in a bad
business. You can increase your value by
building your competitive advantages.
Where does that show up in your
valuation? Remember, the value of growth
comes from earning more than your cost
of capital, right? So, your competitive
advantages become stronger. That number
becomes larger and more sustainable.
Your value goes up. Or you can increase
your
value by reducing your cost of capital.
and we'll talk about the different
pathways to reducing cost of every
restructuring if you cut it to its core
has to show up in one or more of these
places. So let's start with the first
one increasing your cash flows from your
existing assets. In every big
restructuring, there are two words you
will hear. Cost cutting and more
efficient operations. Right? Assuming
you mean what you say. And the reason I
say that lots of companies promise cost
cuts, but you look at what they actually
do. They're not quite delivered. But
assuming you mean what you say, cutting
costs will reduce your operating
expenses, increase your margin, shown to
value. What I'm going to say next is
going to sound mildly unpatriotic or
majorly unpatriotic, but take it for
what it's worth. But I've never believed
that it should be the objective of any
company to maximize taxes paid to the
government. But let me cover myself. You
want to minimize taxes
paid given the tax law. I think that's
legal. So legally, you want to pay as
little in taxes as you can. Where does
it show up in your valuation? What what
ingredient? What
item? The ebit times 1 minus t. Right?
Put a lower t. Everything else goes up.
So maybe you could the third thing you
can do is remember these are cash flows
from existing assets you need
maintenance capex to make the if you can
make that maintenance capex smaller and
keep the assets running that increases
your cash flows and increases value and
if you're a company that has significant
working capital needs inventory
receivables reducing that will increase
your cash flows and increase value. a
retail firm, you bring your working cap
from 2% of revenues to 1%. That's an
increase in cash
flows. It's the easiest place to start,
right? But one of the things I would
caution you on is when you see cost
cutting at companies, sometimes the cost
cutting can actually destroy value.
Let's talk about some of the ways it can
destroy value. Let's say you're looking
at a technology firm that c cuts cost
and increase profits. But you know which
cost it cuts? R&D
expenses. R&D expenses are really not
operating expenses in the first place.
They're there because accountant screwed
up. You cut your R&D expenses. You
increase your earnings from existing
assets. What have you given up on?
Future growth, right? You could also cut
you could pay less in taxes, but you
cross that line between tax, what is it?
Tax avoidance, tax evasion. I don't know
what the what the words are, but you
know what the line I'm talking about.
You pay less in taxes, but then you get
dragged away to jail. You get this big
fine. That's not good value enhancement
in the long term.
You you cut back on maintenance capex,
but you don't just cut back a little
bit. You cut back so much that you're
hurting the capacity to produce the
goods you do. And finally, you cut
working capital to the point that when
people come into your store and they ask
for an item, you can't find it anymore.
This was the mistake that brick and
mortar retail did when Amazon became a
threat. They said, "We're going to cut
inventory." Okay? And then you walk and
you still see it. I mean, right now, you
walk into a store looking for your size.
You can't find it. So, what do you do?
You go back home and you order it on
Amazon online. It's there that evening.
And then brick and mortar retail store
say, "Why is this happening to us? It's
because I can't find a size eight shoe
in your store because you told me to
come back two weeks from now. Maybe
you'll have a size eight in the style
that I
want. So cost cutting at first sight can
look good, but you got to dig a little
deeper. When is cost cutting going to
create value? If you're cutting costs
that are truly unproductive, your
revenues can your maintenance capex is
is being reduced, but you're still
keeping assets going. You're paying less
in taxes, but you're doing it
legally. And that line is going to
determine whether it's going to create
or destroy value. Now let's go back to
the uh the question and I asked at the
start of the class about the four
divisions of a company and said in
general when you run a business and you
look at every asset you own not just
every division every asset there are
three values you can compute for every
asset or every division the first is
what I call a continuing value you know
a continuing value is if I keep holding
on to the asset collect the cash flows
what's the value of the asset going to
be so I'm going to project the expected
cash flows discount back at a reasonable
cost of capital you come up with
continuing value the second yeah go
ahead William that's like a go but on
each asset right going concern is for an
entire company an asset might have a
finite life so basically over the life
of that asset what are the cash so think
of that as your continuing value the
second number you can come up with is
what I call an abandonment value which
is if you shut this asset down or
division down right now and you sold the
assets off for scrap what would I get
right which for
Some things can be high. If you have a
real estate property, it can be high.
But for others, it can be low. The third
is a devestature value. How much would
an outsider pay me for this asset given
what they see in it. The general rule is
for every asset, you want to take the
highest of the three values. So the
continuing value is highest, you want to
hold on to the asset. If the devestature
value is highest, you should sell it no
matter how great the asset looks to you.
And if the abandoned value is even
higher, just abandon the asset.
So if you use that principle on the four
divisions, you can see very quickly why
the worst division might not be a
bestvesture. It might be your AI star
division because that's where company
people will overpay for a
business. So that's the first stop is
cash flows from existing assets. Let's
talk about
growth. When you look at growth, we know
that growth at this point in time, we
have enough nuance on growth, but you
know growth is not always good, right?
Growth can add value, destroy value, or
do nothing for value. And what's the
dividing line between when growth adds
and destroys value, what is the metric
we compared to?
We compare the return capital to the
cost of capital. If it's higher than the
cost of capital, you create value. If
it's less, and I showed you this table,
I think in an earlier part of the class,
or maybe I didn't, where I looked at the
percentage of companies globally that
earned less than their cost of capital
and the percent of companies that earn
more than their cost of capital. truly
depressing table. 30% of companies
globally earn more than their cost of
capital. 70% earn less than their cost
of capital. So let's say you're in the
good h good part, right? You're in the
30%. There I'm going to encourage you to
grow more, right? You reinvest more.
Your value will go up. But if you're in
the 70% that earns less than your cost
of capital, what's your pathway to
creating more value? Reinvest less. In
fact, perhaps stop reinvesting at all.
Don't try to grow. You can't do much
about your existing investments, but at
least you can stop making the hole
deeper. Go growing at a higher rate is
not necessarily good. And in fact, let
me add to that. McKenzie actually did
this study. The reason McKenzie has an
advantage here is they have this
proprietary database of what clients do.
They can track them over time. There's a
if you go to the Mckenzie website, you
can sign up for this magazine called
Mckenzie Quarterly. It's free where
every every 3 months you will get a you
know these 10 or 12 articles where
they've looked at proprietary data. Some
of it is crap but some of it is good. So
this is a McKenzie study that compared
five different ways of growing and it's
categorized them from best to worst.
It's a very strange graph. I don't know
why they did it this way. The way to
read this graph is they measure how much
in additional value you get for every
million dollars that you invest in a
particular way of trying to grow. At the
top of the list was coming up with a new
product. A million dollars invested
creates between $1.75 and $2 million in
additional value. So what would be an
example of a company that created a new
product, reinvented itself?
Well, go back way. A vision pro has done
nothing for Apple as a value, right? But
you're in the right company. Let's go
back 25 years though. Apple in 2000 was
a dying company. It was a PC company
where nobody was buying its PCs. Not a
good place to be. Second coming of Steve
Jobs. So how did that game start?
Well, it started with the iTunes and the
iPod and then the iPhone and then the
iPad and the I hostage on Netflix and
that's but basically the eye came in and
kind of reinvented new product.
The only catcher is I actually looked at
the raw data that McKenzie had on this
new product thing and it turns out that
the average value created is 1.75 to 2
million but only 20% of companies that
try to come up with a new product
actually succeed. Those successes are
huge. It skews the average up. So it's a
low odds high payoff strategy.
McKenz Microsoft between 1990 and 2013
tried probably 25 different products.
None of them caught
on until they got to the cloud and they
reinvented
themselves. Let's go one step down.
Expanding an existing
market. Any examples of company that's
expanded an existing
market? Can be geographic, right?
No, it can be Corona saying, you know,
we're going to take beer me and expand
into the US. It can
be Novo Nordisk accidentally expanding
its market by doing what? Taking a drug
that they thought would treat diabetes
and then discovering it was a weight
loss drug. It's completely
accidental, but your value could go up.
Yeah. Uber in fact with Uber delivery.
Right. Right. That was an expansion of
their existing their regular their
traditional market was ride sharing and
Uber Eats has actually turned out to be
much more successful in terms of making
money for Uber than Uber ride sharing
right expanding an existing market. The
third and third in the list so million
dollars invested there creates.3 to 75
million additional value maintaining a
growing share in a growing
market. Let's take Nvidia, right? It's
got an 80% market share of the AI chip
market. That's bad, right? When you have
an 80% market share, there's not much
room to grow. You got almost a do. But
what saves
them? The chip market right now is about
80 billion. The chip market itself is
supposed to grow to half a billion. You
can actually have your market share go
down and still be okay because the
market itself is growing. And then you
get to the bottom of the of the barrel.
And here are the two bottom strategies.
One is competing for share in a stable
market. Why is it so difficult to create
value when you're competing for market
share in a stable market?
Yes. Cuz you got to compete on price,
right? You got to cut prices. You get a
higher market share, but you have lower
margins. So if Chipotle wants to grow,
it's going to be really difficult to do
it without essentially giving up on
margins. And the net effect can be
negative. And you probably guess what's
at the bottom of the list. Worst
possible growth strategy. Because by now
we've dumped on acquisitions already.
Might as well take one final dump and
leave
it. Worst possible way to grow
historically has been through inorganic
growth, acquiring other companies. And
does that surprise you? And I don't know
about you, but my mother would tell me
that you if you don't work for it, you
won't earn it. Right? What are you doing
in acquisitions? You let somebody else
build something for you because you're
in a hurry. Yeah. And when you let
somebody else build, you're right, you
get to the market quicker, but you're
going to pay an upfront price that takes
away much of your value added. I mean,
that's where I think we've got to give
Microsoft credit for the way Satin
Nadella built the cloud business. He
didn't acquire a cloud company. He built
it from scratch within Microsoft.
That's why I thought his Activision was
a mistake because you want to build a
gaming company, do it within Microsoft.
You have the skill, you have the the
players to do it. Anytime a company
tries to jump ahead in the queue by
doing an acquisition. It's true. You you
save time, but you end up paying a price
that over time has been difficult to
overcome.
I'm not a corporate strategist and I
don't want to be
one. I've wondered about the strategy
class. You have a strategy class, right?
You have to go through. Is it called
strategy? It's probably called something
else. Management,
something what the role of strategy is
in valuation. And I think I found a role
for it. Ultimately, strategy is about
coming up with competitive advantages.
An entire Michael Porter book of the
five forces. What is that? Five. I I
kind of vaguely remember the graphic
keeps showing up in my valuations. Look
at the Michael Porter thing, you know,
supply competition. It's all about, hey,
how do you create a competitive
advantage? So, in valuation, competitive
advantages matter because they determine
how much you can make over the cost of
capital and how long you can do it.
So one of the things you know and Warren
Buffett talks a lot about these and he
uses a word to capture competitive
advant what's the word that oldtime
value investors and Warren Buffett used
what were competitive
advantages moes right moes are a big
deal you want deep moes you want wide
moes makes me think of medieval castles
and crocodiles but basically you want
crocodiles in that moat you want to make
sure nobody can cross the moat so let's
talk about different modes and how they
play out in valuation. One mode can be
brand name. We talked about the value of
a brand name. The advantage of having a
top brand name is you get the pricing
power and that pricing power shows up as
higher margins and higher value. What if
it's just a name brand? Name brand is
not just a a top brand, but people
recognize your name. You're Converse,
right? I'm not paying a premium for
Converse shoes, but Converse is a name I
recognize like in the middle. Oh, you
name you don't even have a name. You let
anybody slap whatever name they want on
your product. You have a generic product
from No. So in terms of modes, wide mode
to no mode. Switching
cost. It's a switching cost.
Yes. Tyler
cost to use product.
That's actually close. You know what a
switching cost really does for you? It
makes the cost of switching into your
product as low as possible. But once
they've switched in, you want to make
the cost of switching out as high as
possible. What cell service do you
use? Verizon 8. What mo T-Mobile? Walk
by a Verizon store, walk in, and tell
them you're a T-Mobile customer. You
know what they're going to do? You'll
have four salespeople around you, and
they will all convince you that in the
next 15 minutes, they can switch you to
Verizon. No problem. middle year.
So, so basically you walk by a lot of
stores obviously every two years and so
when you switch basically they want to
make the cost of switching in as easy as
possible. We'll make it
effortless. So 15 minutes later you've
been switched and they give you a 24page
document in fine print that you have to
sign. It'll put all the conditions on
the things you've agreed to like your
first born I think is part of it. Now
know your house, your whatever it is.
Basically, they want to make the cost of
switching out as high as
possible. I have an iPhone 10. I'm
completely okay with it. But AT&T knows
I have an iPhone 10 and they don't seem
to be completely okay with it. The
amount of messages I get every day
offering me the latest iPhone. and you
can come in and switch for free, which
is a complete lie. It's not a switch for
free. It's I switch and I'm locked in
for the next 24 months. It's a way of
keeping the cost of switching out as
high as possible. Good businesses make
the cost of switching in low, the cost
of switching out as high as possible.
Right? Network
benefits. We talked about this in the
context of Uber, right? What's the
networking benefit? is as you get bigger
it gets easier to get bigger because you
have a platform everybody wants to be on
it. If you have strong global networking
benefits, you essentially are able to
draw huge market share. Facebook and
Google have huge networking benefits
globally. Gives them an immense market
share of the global advertising market.
You have local networking benefits.
You're in some part of the world or
city. It's weaker but it's still
potential advantage. Or you might have
no networking benefits.
People cost advantage.
Cost advantages basically mean it cost
you less to make a product than your
competitors. Be nice to have permanent
cost advantages, right? Have you talked
about a company that
does? Talked about a Ramco
remember it's a Ramco's cost
advantage. 300 million barrels of oil
under the Saudi
sands. And that advantage is not going
away. There is no other part of the
world where you can get oil at at even
twice that cost. Basically, it's cost
advantage. It's nailed in. Which is the
reason Aramco can pay $124 billion in
dividends last year and still have cash
left
over your cost advantages can be
temporary, which is you have a cost
advantage right now, but this two shall
pass. I was around when the PC business
took off, right? The first PCs, the
first dominant company in the PC
business was
IBM. It very quickly lost an advantage
because it cost IBM too much to make a
computer. The company that beat it out
was Compact. By the late 80s, Compact
was the lower cost. That lasted about
four years because Dell came along and
then Dell was cheaper than Compact. So,
Dell replaced Compact as the lowest
cost. four or five years later, Lenovo
came along and know the cost advantages
here are temporary because they come
from something you're doing, but other
people find a way to do it even cheaper.
And finally, if you can get legal
protection against competition, would
you like that? Hey, that's effectively
what we're getting with patents,
right? If the protection is complete,
it's great, right? You're a monopoly.
But be careful what you wish for because
often when you're granted a monopoly by
the government, what does the government
take away in return?
It takes away your pricing power. Think
about what the great thing about being a
monopoly is right. I know you're saying
take being great. No, set aside all your
moral views about monopolies. Think
about being a monopoly. Everybody hates
you, right? You're a monopoly. How do
you get back at them? You charge them
more. makes you feel a lot better. 40%
more for you. Hey, they don't like you,
but they have to pay the 40% more. But
if you're a regulated monopoly,
everybody still hates you. You're the
phone company. You get ready to charge
them 40% more, and the regulator says
this year 1.5%
more. Do you see why sometimes it's
better to leave the regulated monopoly
and actually become a competitive
company? It might actually you give up
the protection, but at least you get
back pricing
power. So when you look at companies,
that's what you look for. So next
session when we start we're going to
talk a little bit about the the the the
cost to capital but it'll be part as
part of the last session after I
presented your results. So I will see
you on Monday. Oh one more thing I will
have office hours on Friday just for the
project right so this is not about the
final exam this is about people with
lastm minute questions. I thought about
whether to do it Friday or Saturday but
I think Saturday will be too late so I
want to do it Friday. So you have
questions that come up in your
regressions and your pricing and your
DCFS. So I'll send you the details about
the Zoom session or you can ask those
questions to
Yeah.
you forwarding. Yeah,
it's a it's also
so once I have
my and then I guess I should
take how much
It's
like
30% to their operating income. from last
year which
will return on
capital. So I
think invest capitaliz
actually high R&D
performing operating because usually
when you have high R&D both
income actually goes
down
low as the expense minus the
amatization reflect fast.
So
effective
surge even if you take this and you make
it if this works 18 202 the
effect that's going to start to happen
because this is small scaling
up so your starting capital is really
good but that's part of the drive the
pro
So ultimately that's what's going to
drive them because so much of the
expensive R&D which is fresh in the same
time
they know what analysts are expecting
their
president almost every single
time we are
invest and the other follow question I
have is that
we
capital there's also a special debt
structure compared to like Tesla for
example Tesla 25% of their liabilities
is theft is transparent depth but only
6.5%
45 which is vary. So most of their
liability comes to the account payables
to their like suppliers. Yeah. So they
have like a huge huge advantage on like
the paid as well as the losing supplier
credit
grows smaller. But as you stand up that
supplier
credit now a hundred billion dollar
company kind of suppliers indeed doing
this to you becomes more and fewer so
over time that advantage will become
lesser because Amazon started like that
as well supplex
it's going to have potential depth. So
you still have a debt
ratio which is much
so like for example apparently they have
like 20 debt and they paid 30% of it
last year. So they like lower depth and
I would say like given the Chinese
special like industry supply flexible
flexibilities and it's dominant in China
maybe would you say like a four or 4.5
cells to capital sustain in the long
term for like 10 years
what what is it you
think what's your margin margin is
currently a Apple right sales tax margin
is your
return gives
you% of your return capital and that's
your return capital long term right so
that basically really high
capital you go through the sales of
capital you will have to come down just
that steady skill
if you're assuming
15% instantly you're assuming the sales
ratio coming down
to essentially almost 1.5 right so it's
already embed in your valuation so we're
using a sales cap just in the next 10
years the
return capital but much much
lower so the real question we're asking
is have they built enough cover much of
the next 10 years or so the answer is
the 4.5 is in fact a good reflection of
what I was doing. But you're being
realistic after the 10 years if I'm
making that return capital. So if I use
like five sales rate, it's uh it's fine
that I didn't make
sure because I currently I take an
average of like the other manufacturer
and I only capitalize uh the part that
exceeds 5% because I get around like
7.5%. So I
only more so this adjustment.
Yeah. Yeah.
What is your most recent?
Yeah.
Okay. I was also
like
spreadsheet again.
And then the things you use in the
statistical data analys
or tab or whatever.
Excel spreadsheet with all the numbers
and use statistics or
sorry. Okay. I have a question.
office say thank
you for
before and I
[Music]
think the fact that I'm going to
connect a
lot for everything and have fun at the
wedding. You take the the exam and prom
you approved it.
Thank you so much, Professor. Take care.
Bye. Bye.
I mean, it's incredibly important. No
matter how nice
some
other is%
So 78